diese blöden sprünge das einfachste was
es in meinem kopf kommen die schnauze
dich zu köln ist noch einfacher herzlich
willkommen zur ersten folge von gate
venture aber nicht allein sondern er hat
mal wieder vereint in einem ganz neuen
projekt und zwar in drei gleich gehts
los in der in zweierteams wir haben ein
gutes format und zwar geld werden
chappaz glaube ich ganz gut so zu deiner
halskette vor allem auch immer es kann
ja ja ja ja und warum geld meine high
speed ist ich gehe weil der halskette
ski ohne aaron merke dass wir sind nicht
es folgen also es gibt es gibt lief und
wir spielen
wir spielen hier eine jump n run webber
ich will auch die heißt wie wie heißt
sie die heißt blue shell heißt jede
machen das folgendermaßen die erste
folge kommt bei jedem von unseren leuten
also von jedem von uns
mein gott die nächste folge dann bei mir
danach bei
nach der haupt folge bei dem die zweite
und die dritte kommt dann immer bei mir
genau die uns allen noch einmal
zusammenfassen kommen wir können das
geld doch alles ist eine playliste
zusammen nachschauen genau danach eine
playlist auf dem channel playlist geben
da können die alle videos und ja wir
kennen diese map noch gar nicht es gibt
hierfür drin ein eigenes texture pack
drin
das heißt blue shell parcours also ist
es nicht die voll aber sieht die von
macys auswahl des textes hat ein pokal
auf den kopf was ist los was hast du in
die kann man sich was ich will ist es
auch was die machen wir hier hier musst
du okay böse sachen erstmal okay ich
habe auch schon die rüstung an gibt es
auch ein helm oder nicht sie sind ist ja
ok
was nämlich was nämlich
ich bin cherry face detection 14 face
und nein nicht hinten rein gesetzt auch
man und
wieso können wir nicht ersetzen eine
bestimmte härtetest wollen manchmal okay
dann bin ich golden kautschuk mir egal
schon mal hier den dingen es nicht so
wissen golden globe als lasst uns mal
die sache staaten liegen ich habe schon
ein bisschen voraus geschaut ist
eigentlich gar nicht so wild hier aber
ließen so die parcours angezeigt
sparkurs wo man sehen kann was für das
hier so vor kommen bakterien habe ich
gar keinen bock drauf persönlich der
streit der kommentare
schlecht und hier sind gemacht irgendwie
das terrarium das richtig heiß gemacht
die federboa dahinter habt ihr food
dabei also könnt ihr nämlich was abgeben
ok ich hole mir schnell food und dann
können wir dann leben wir direkt los
start ins erste level ein palaver gibt
und wenn ihr einfach auf den reiter
playlist geht müsste die eine playlist
namens gate venture irgendwie sehen und
dort sind alle videos ganz komfortabel
für euch aufgelistet die sie dann lasst
uns das abenteuer beginnen dass chris
gehabt 16 und wir machen das kompetitive
also battles hatte markus ist ein buch
mormon skizziert versammeln und loslegen
wenn logo nicht ausreichen würde
okay der macht status ja oft wir machen
einfach mal das erstmals wettbewerb
wahrscheinlich danach wird okay 321 ja
vorhin schlagen ihr nutzen söhne darf
man nicht dankeschön dafür nicht
schlagen
also nein das ist kein muss man wieder
dahin zu schlagen ist volker schlag erst
mal erstmal ohne schlagen
denn gerade da muss man ja okay jetzt
habe ich ihn geschlagen auch passiert
was nicht im rechten maustaste drückt da
nicht noch mal auf den hebel uns ist der
checkpoint zu doch habe ich gemacht aber
man weiß nicht wie oft ich gedrückt habe
deswegen ist es nicht vorhersehbare zahl
ist alles wieder offen wahrscheinlich
einmal marcellino hier rechtsklick so
jetzt der typ macht es die tür einfach
natürlich etwas kompliziert das mit dem
app store
ich bin ein mittel
darüber kommt darüber statt du musst
hier überlaufen ist ja sehr gut
da kann man da kann man laufen und
laufen oder ich bin schon wieder ganz
woanders hier der ganz kleine wie billig
das ist alter kann man von laufen
ach komm mir jetzt noch ein bisschen
kompliziert man sagt ja aus 0 2 hinten
irgendwo ne nein drei sind doch oder 33
pro dieses level 13 titel und zwei am
ende doch nicht für jeden
okay okay okay okay halt dass schon
jemand gemacht ich genommen kurz hier
zurück ich habe nämlich etwas gefunden
geriet alles klar hier oben waren die
diamonds trennte sich durch geholt ahmed
gewesen wenn man die dort findet die
damen die sind in kästen city so
christen nicht mist ich will auch in
deutschland gibt mir ein ich war dieses
mal leitet wieder hallo ich bin so ein
idiot gehört hast du schon gefunden
3 hinten und zwei am ende also 32 also
delikt fiel damals darf dass es auch
unter wird gerne eine wieder jemand weiß
ja nicht ob das ja auch diamonds
schlagstöcke ein stück also bei disney
stoppt ihn
ich hab schon noch irgendwo dass man
glaubt dass man alles von dann wechseln
können wir das doch ganz schön böse
was wäre glaube ich gar nicht alles so
lange wahrscheinlich mal gucken geht
eigentlich wird dann entsprechend die
partner anpasst 14 10 minuten oder so
nicht mit in sieben minuten an der ein
parcours und unsere bremach ihm noch ein
paar kein machen wir noch kommt in
diesen kaktus kann man das erst scheiß
kakteen jump die für conti des partner
der skihang sexy hat ja dann machen wie
der startschuss
was ich mal kurz wieder dingens okay ich
kann das nicht lesen ok you can find the
diamonds and of course vornehmen zb n24
diamanten jetzt wie ist die aktuelle
wertung für das habt ihr ja 23 beide 23
hallo gust behindert kommt zurück zur
strafe als du musst warten
nein warte 32 fertig los
12 auch im natürlich dann drüber ist ein
willkommene möglichkeit das gerät
bekommen
ich bin auch ich meine natürlich nein
ich bin auch ingenieurs ich laufe
einfach direkt runter weiter und die man
weiter an sich ist vom tisch
nein dafür bekommst du selbst erleben
achten so ein bisschen gibt ja einfach
zum gold apfel dann kann ja nichts
passieren
hierunter fallen harte checks gemacht
wie schwierig das wir gescheitert gut
dass ich den checkpoint aufgemacht habe
achim löschen der ort ist alter das ist
richtig tricky jump gehört an die art
wie wir wissen
getippt werden jetzt um man nicht
darunter fallen nach faktor spricht der
behörden warum jetzt
dessen job gefunden
im letzten sprung neuen hast du alle da
hinten gefunden und auch diana richtige
reingebracht habe ich jetzt einen das
gibt's doch nicht
nein diese blöden sprünge das einfachste
was ist in minecraft kommen die schnauze
dich zu killen es noch einfacher
oder 12 was ist denn der andere weg da
war das war das ebenen dingens diamant
der andere weg da hinten
der andere weg dahin warten diamant ja
ja die habe ich nämlich eben gesehen die
wollt ich kann eben auch schnecken aber
ich bin so richtig die missgeburt in
diesem konzert alter einfach vor mir
steht aber es gibt noch welche da
versteckt irgendwo war geil geil aber
erst geben muss erstmal jetzt noch
weiter machen natürlich nicht schlimmer
sogar um prämien gucken wo keiner ist
oder so jetzt habe ich auch das ziel
erreicht aber ich gehe nicht aus dieser
runde raus und die als kind braucht es
gibt in den sommer auf spanisch
verlieren
wie viel wie vier diaz gibt's in dem
level 4 567 müsste es eigentlich
geblieben müsste es geben ich habe ja
ich habe mir ein ich habe also einen 1
gibt es noch recht allen geht's gut
ja ich würde jetzt einfach mal behaupten
da ist noch einiges offen meine freunde
sowieso
ja ich habe ihn gefunden ich hatte ja
angekündigt
der comcom wird sich fetzen
der kaktus auch der milch gegeben
macht mal irgendwie / bonpoint damit ihr
immer wieder hier an diesen ansatz level
ausfall schon versterben solltet ihr
müsst ihr kurz vor ostern ja wir wissen
ja noch ein nein das wäre auch in
letzten passiert wer kein friendly fires
gewesen wie immer nur stress der junge
zweimal die wir stecken wir den ein mit
der rüstung
das sind die russen ganz klar dass der
krebs kommen die welt als nächste dran
du hast gewonnen' ich ergebe mich zu
ändern hier die erste folge auf jeden
fall minuten aber werden bei den
nächsten folge schon fünf minuten
partien kriegen ja aber nur zwei bis
drei pro haushalt geben pro folge mal
gucken wir dann die eben dauern mal
gucken und ich verspreche dass ich mich
mehr ansteigen der nächsten folge mensch
das gibt es ja nicht
nächstes mal bei mir am morgen war schon
auf morgen wahrscheinlich
ich bin programm
morgen so